thank you
okay we will open up the hearing for
Senate Bill 258 and I'd like to
recognize
Senator Coke
it's a Polish name so it's rhymes with
polka just in case that helps I should
have known that I'm sorry yeah
well welcome to Public Works and please
proceed thank you so much
um nice to be here with you guys today
um chair and members of the committee
for the record I'm Senator Rebecca
Perkins quoka representing Senate
District 21 which is the city of
Portsmouth and surrounding towns
so SB 258 is a refile of legislation
that
um I introduced last year and
um both years we've we've had success in
the Senate but we've run into some
questions in the house so
um we brought this piece of legislation
back to address a specific situation in
my district in the town of Newington
there's a question between
New Hampshire dot the town of Newington
and the Newington Historical Society
about how to dispose of a former Railway
Depot and so what we're looking to do in
this piece of legislation is to enable
historical Societies in addition to
municipalities to be eligible
transferees
um and so that's the goal of the
language as proposed it's been through
many versions and I hope that you can
find this one acceptable the city of
Newington in this case does not want to
act as legal transferee and prefers not
to be sort of a legal intermediary and
so there are probably other historical
properties that are in a similar status
across the state which I think some
members of the preservation Alliance are
here to speak to today but the
historical society is willing and able
to take the this property and would like
to and so I urge you to um
move out to pass on SB 258 to allow for
preservation of this Railway Depot in
Newington and so many other historic and
cultural resources across our state and
with that I'm happy to take any
questions Mr chair any questions for the
senator
yes please
representative Barbara
thank you Mr chairman
thank you for my question
um I have a question in the language
here under Section 1A line six
and then in comparison to Roman numeral
two section line 13. they seem to be one
line is saying that you're going to want
to sell it for whatever price below
market value and then in the next
section it says
not to sell it below market value and
I'm kind of uh
confused a little bit on how that works
and who determines at what point it's
under fair market value because
personally I don't understand why the
state would sell anything under market
value okay thank you thank you for your
question representative so the
construction of the language is intended
um
in lines four through nine two
sort of Define a circumstance under
which a property would be
able to be conveyed for less than
firmware fair market value so in lines
12 and 13 what we're doing is you know
sort of pointing to that exception the
public policy reason behind that
exception would be
as we read in lines four and five to say
that
um there are circumstances in which it
would be deemed to be in the overall
public interest to
transfer at less than fair market value
and so that would be based on the
historical social environmental or
economic benefits
um of the property so we're trying to
create a carve out essentially between
those two provisions
follow-up
then uh
so who's going to make that
determination as far as historical
social environmental and economical
value who makes that determination sure
and I'm I'm sure that the assistant
administrator of dot is best positioned
to speak to the extensive process that
um this small piece of Statute is a part
of but uh that you know dot has
significant jurisdiction and discretion
to
act here and so they have an existing
process that is is quite complicated
we're not seeking to change that we're
just seeking to give the commissioner in
line four
um the discretion
when you know particular circumstances
arise such as this historical Railway
Depot
to transfer to for example the
Historical Society instead of its hands
being tied because it can only transfer
to the municipality
thank you
uh thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
Senator uh I'm curious why you decided
to give the commissioner this power
rather than the long-range committee
this power which they already have over
at market value transfers
it's a very good question
um
and
I think that the question the answer
likely lies in
um trying to find something that works
for all parties I know that the long
range committee does have discretion
over certain disposals but I think where
we ended up fitting this
into statute um
you know it just it made sense to have
the dot be the party that was sort of
I guess acting on that and behind me is
Ben Foster New Hampshire Housing and um
the assistant
administrator at Dot and so you know
there's a very complicated process and I
do too so maybe they can speak to that
in more detail
thank you Mr chairman uh Senator my
question is why in this bill as it's
written then and I understand the intent
are your singling out just Highway and
Turnpike probably rather than property
purchase with General funds or fish and
game why not open it up to property
purchase with those funds as well and
any other funds sure I um it's a very
good question as well and as you know
dot has a tremendous number of
properties and so we've been through
extensive discussions to kind of
um figure out the best way to limit it I
think that
um
the more limited it is perhaps the
easier it is for for parties to agree to
but I would certainly be open to a
change like what you're suggesting in
other words follow-ups you would be open
to amending it to include other
properties other than Highway and
Turnpike funded properties I would
whether the other folks in this room
would agree the number question yeah
okay good thank you
um represent Mills thank you Mr chair uh
yes I'm I'm a little concerned as to why
normally if something like this comes
before us it comes with the town of
newington's total blessing uh and
specifically on line 14 it says if a
town city or county decides to resell
the property it shall first off offer
the property to the state at market
value so there there is some specific
language already that
we we as a committee shouldn't be
handling this directly on the state
level it should be taken care of through
the town first
uh thank you for the question and there
are
um again folks here to testify from
Newington but part of the reason we're
in front of you is
um that we have tried through various
Avenues to convince the town of
Newington
um to just merely act as an intermediary
and this and they are are not interested
in that option so I believe
and again I don't want to um speak over
the experts behind me but
I believe that the town you know
essentially is first offered the
property and then
um if this sort of situation arises
where there's sort of an exception that
fits these criteria historical social or
economic benefit
um
you know that those are the situations
in which we sort of consider
transferring to a third party besides
municipality follow-up
thank you Mr Jerry yeah because the way
this sounds is this is this is a bill
that is specifically designed around one
simple piece of property and it brings
no benefit to anybody else and the fact
that the town we're we're not usually in
the position that we override anything
that a town would have jurisdiction over
if if they wanted to do this and when
people want Bridges named when they want
city parks named we always make sure
that the town signs off on it first of
all and it's with their blessing and
then we'll go ahead and consider it so
I'm just going to tell you I'm having a
hard time considering over riding the
town's interest in this thank you sure
and if they may just respond they I
completely understand your opinion um
and I think the intent here is not
necessarily to be overriding the
municipality but rather in circumstances
where the town is not interested to have
another Avenue
represent Faulkner
yes thank you
my preference by saying my understanding
of what this does
this just adds something there is a
paragraph one in the current bill which
stays there which says that if there is
Surplus property Surplus Highway
property
it's offered first to the municipality
and then paragraph two says if you know
if it goes to Mrs municipality it will
pay fair market Price
what we're inserting in is at 1A
which would be you know be you know if
one doesn't occur because you have to
offer to the town first
if that doesn't happen then they can
sell it
at lower the market value one of these
other situations applies
uh in in which case paragraph two
doesn't come into
play because it's not the municipality
so I I think we're missing if we had
reprinted paragraph one I think it might
be a little bit easier to understand so
I think
were
the relationship between 1A and two is
there isn't any
other than to accept that out
okay
um per episode
uh in section two are Roman numeral two
uh it says if the town city or county
decides to resell the property and the
intent is to sell it to the historical
society is the Historical Society
owned by the town city or anything like
that or is it an entity upon itself
so I think there's two
um two separate items there if I may
representative so I think
it's a really simple subject so if um in
lines 14 and 15 I think that's
concerning if the municipality was the
transferee which in this circumstance
we're asking that it not be
um separately your question was was the
historical society owned by the town or
city and the answer is no it's a private
non-profit entity so
um I think lines 14 and 15 would apply
to the town I think what we're trying to
do is have um lines four through nine
apply to the private entity
representative Newman
yes thank you
thank you for taking this question and I
will preface it that maybe it's my
reading of it or punctuation but going
back to lines six and seven the subject
property may be disposed or leased at
less than fair market value comma as
determined by the governor and Council
is the determination by the governor and
Council as to whether it be disposed or
leased or to determine that it's at
below fair market value that is a very
good question representative I I believe
that is intended to modify less than
fair market value because it's the you
know I think it's the commissioner that
has the discretion to exercise the
exception
um
but I can look into that and make sure
I'm speaking correctly okay just to
follow up on I guess on that fine point
so
I'm trying to get my my head around it
so it's determined that it's at less
than fair market value but there would
have to be some documentation saying the
value is here
and because now it's
considering being conveyed for this now
we know it's below Fair how do you
confirm
what what it is sure and um thank you if
possible I'm likely going to defer that
question to dot because I'm I'm sure
that they have a process for determining
the market value like an appraisal when
they go through this process
um so I think the intent here again is
just it's to add
some discretion for the commissioner in
circumstances where you know the town
does not want the property and there is
another transferee
and they can come to agreement with DOT
um but they are not the municipality
okay
if I could of course sure
so the process at present so this
property we're talking about a specific
property so this property is is an old
train station is that what this is yes
okay
and it's state owned at this point in
time or did the state it stayed on the
parcel right isn't in Dot's ownership
yeah okay so if
under normal circumstances
someone they it was determined that this
was going to be disposed of there was
someone saying that they wanted this
property and they would ask the state to
consider selling it goes through a
process it has an appraisal
groups come forward and say whether they
usually don't do that unless there's a
group that comes forward and says they
want to purchase that
and the process would be then first it
would be offered to the town it might be
and there's a
a group of
parties that might have the first shot
at it and then it would be offered to
the public after that
has there been an appraisal on the
property to start with there must have
been an appraisal I can ask dot about
that I I will let him confirm it I
believe I just heard him confirm that
there would normally be an appraisal yes
so I I there's language in here that I'd
love to become more comfortable with
this because when I first heard the
conversation I believe you said that it
was for historical or preservation
purposes
when I read when I read line four and
five
it talks about an overall public
interest based on historical social
environmental or economic benefits
or is for a non-proprietary government
use that seems like a lot broader
language than what I heard the
introduction for which was for
historical and preservation
um I'm sure you didn't craft this but
you what what can you it seems that if
we were to pass this that this is a
pretty open book as to
um I know what no idea what social would
be is social interest I have no idea
what an economic benefit or
non-proprietory government use can you
help me with why that language is such
sure
um and you're right here I did not craft
it although I did add historical into it
um the way it came back so I think that
we would certainly be open to narrowing
it the intent here was that if we're you
know I think if we're going to go to the
trouble of sort of everybody
understanding the process and creating a
carve out that we make sure we capture
properties that might have other
benefits I I cannot myself really think
of other ones you know I think of things
like
um
in Portsmouth we have the albacore you
know like sitting on some land near the
highway I don't that probably falls in
the category of historical as well but
it's just I think they're sort of
examples where you know if D.O.T felt
like it would be helpful to have a
little bit broader language the narrower
then we could keep this and if
you guys are not comfortable with it we
could narrow it to historical because
I'm sure that covers most circumstances
okay thank you any further questions at
this time yes please represent Melbourne
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
could you tell me the size of the lot
I'm sorry could you tell me the size of
the lot
um I cannot but
thank you
further questions and we'll have
opportunity please represent beggar oh
thank you Mr chair and thanks for taking
my question sure
when we heard this bill before I believe
one of the questions that was brought up
is is it
if in fact something happened let's say
you did give it to historical did
transfer it to the Historical Society
they go and they increase the value of
the Depot or whatever
and then 10 years from now they go
defunct
um
how do you determine what the value of
the property is at that time does it
take into consideration
you know how things were improved and
then how could we uh
be assured that we would basically get a
get the property back
in under what conditions sure I thank
you for the question representative I
don't think the intent is to make sure
that the state can
get the property back but I believe and
and again I'm gonna have folks that are
way closer to this process on a
day-to-day basis confirmed but my
understanding is that you know if the
D.O.T were to convey the property it
does so subject to Historic preservation
covenants and so
the deed would be restricted to the uses
um that the exception was granted for
and so that would factor into the value
so for example
you know if the Historical Society
receives the property
the deed says this property can only be
used for historic preservation they
improve it they can't just sell it again
you know on on the market they sort of
they have to act pursuant to the
covenants and the deed and so those
purposes would restrict the use
one second yes follow-up
thank you Mr chair well I guess what I'm
getting at more is I'm trying to but
yeah and that is is it if 10 years from
now let's say the the value of the
property is going up they decided they
put a lot of money into it but they it's
still now is going to Funk
How does it go back to the
to the state and is there any potential
claim for that the property's been
improved and now therefore
you know as far as trying to settle on
the value of the property and there's
not a claim that that's been improved
and now because you're getting three
times as much for it that that they
should get some thank you yeah and thank
you because your question just prompted
memory of mine from
again dot can confirm but there's a
reversion Clause included in the
conveyance from dot so
um
I'll I'll have to let the assistant
administrator speak to the circumstances
under which that would take effect but
there is a protection for the state for
it to come back under certain
circumstances and we did look at
drafting something into this bill last
year to accommodate that very
circumstance and in the end I think at
least on the Senate side the legislators
were comfortable with what the language
dot provided that we didn't need that
um so maybe
they could he could cover that more
detail for you okay thank you okay thank
you representative Kaczynski
yeah
oh no I I apologize I thought my hearing
was bad yeah thank you thank you Mr
chairman I apologize thank you Mr
chairman and thank you senator for
taking my question I want to expand just
a little bit on the Chairman's
questioning uh line five it says or
economic benefits could you give me
any kind of a specific example of what
you would consider an economic benefit
yeah it's thank you representative for
the question it's a good question and I
you know I'm trying to think of
um
an example that would fit one I can
think of is for example if there was
something that would serve as a tourist
attraction you know like if the if it
wasn't necessarily a historical property
but rather a parcel that could be
conveyed that would bring
economic benefits through additional
tourism coming to our state I it's not
what this is crafted to cover and so
again if you guys feel this is too broad
we're certainly open to narrowing it but
um
but I I think that's sort of the intent
something in the public interest
thank you yeah
yes we're gonna have an opportunity to
speak to others but please go ahead
represent Barber
thank you Mr chairman
um
hopefully my last question that's fine
it was spurred on by the other
Representatives question at the town
city or county decides to resell the
property to show first off for the
property to the state at the market
value but you stated also that the
historical society is neither
of the above so they would not be a
party to that agreement and then they
could actually dispose of the property
any way they wish after they've received
it is that correct so yes and that's
um what I was trying to explain to
representative Edgar
um there is there's a reversion class
that comes with the conveyance in the
deed and I'm going to have to ask dot to
speak to this in more detail but
under certain circumstances the property
would revert back to the state and
um and again
we looked at trying to protect the
state's interest because it would not
fall under lines 14 and 15 in this case
and and again this the senators were
comfortable we didn't need that but you
may determine differently
thank you seeing no further questions
Sandra thank you thank you guys very
much and I'm going to go back to the
chamber thanks guys
I'd like to bring forward Adam Smith New
Hampshire dot perhaps maybe we could
clear up some questions here please
and we'll accept your testimony but we'd
like to get to the questions that were
concerning D.O.T after that perhaps sure
turn it on again Christian
red bun there you go thank you for
having me here today
um
so I'm Adam Smith I'm the assistant
administrator with the Bureau of
right-of-way I'm standing in today for
Steve Labonte who couldn't be here today
the department wishes to remain neutral
on this bill
but we're here to provide some general
comments and to answer some general
questions today
um
so let me let me start off by saying uh
at the January 31st
2023 meeting Steve Labonte made a
statement uh talking about Dot and the
Bureau of right-of-way and the the fact
is where the Real Estate Group for DOT
so we have appraisers we have surveyors
we have right-of-way agents and then
we'll have property managers that are
responsible for disposals of State
interest after projects are built so
it's kind of the cleanup or the disposal
of Remnant pieces pieces that are no
longer needed for Department use at the
end of projects
so as drafted the proposed legislation
it would open avenues for the Department
to dispose of properties for less than
fair market value
the exception that is created in this in
this RSA 439 C
is mirrored after language that's in the
code of federal regulations if you want
that citation at CFR 23 710 410.
and basically that speaks to the exact
language that was put into this draft
bill which I believe our office our
department helped craft some of that
language
um that speaks to the the social
um
yeah the social uh piece of that
legislation I'm looking for the exact
language bear with me line five line
five
thank you
yeah so the exact language historic
social environmental and economic
benefits
um that's directly out of the CFR
so
um
just wanted to clarify that real quick
another thing that Steve Labonte said at
the January 31st meeting hearing was
that this legislation if adopted is not
going to be a blank check to sell
properties for pennies on the dollar we
still have a responsibility to balance
uh the Department's specific obligations
we have a lot of money that is given
obviously for Federal Highway
development and if it's not used for
that we still owe that money back to the
Federal Highway so
um
you know it's got to be used and
discretionary so we we want it we want
to kind of uh be very careful how this
this would be deployed
so if the if this bill is passed there
are several things that would have to
happen for the Department to go forth
and actually execute uh selling property
less than fair market value one of the
first things we'd have to do is we'd
have to amend our right-of-way manual
which is which is uh
it's reviewed every five years it's
approved by Federal Highway and
basically it's our Playbook of how we do
do business for the department and
specifically if we're going to be
selling property less than fair market
value that process and that rationale
has to be outlined in the in the
right-of-way manual
so that would be the first thing we'd
have to do
um and that's no small that's no small
feat we have been working with groups
like New Hampshire Housing Finance over
the last few years to see if there's any
agreements on potential language that
could be used
to help with that justification that
would be approved by Federal Highway we
have reached out to Federal Highway a
couple times and gotten some buy-in on
on some language so there's there is
some groundwork that's been done now the
specific situation was
properties that would be suitable for
Workforce Development housing not
necessarily what we were talking about
before with the sale of historic
properties like the Newington Depot
um so there are scenarios uh
where the department could
transfer property to third parties uh
another scenario we have mitigation
properties they either have Wetland
mitigation restrictions or historic
restrictions
and then those are to offset project
impacts those are then held by the
department the department struggles with
being the steward of those properties so
we're always struggling with that so
oftentimes we're approached by
conservation groups that want to take on
those stewardship responsibilities this
legislation could help pave the way to
transfer a piece of property to a
conservation group for those stewardship
responsibilities and be actively managed
so
getting to
how we would do it after the
right-of-way manual would be
amended we would still anticipate going
to long range we would still obviously
go to GNC so the process for disposing
of surplus land would remain the same
and it would still be vetted in multiple
layers so I want I just want to
kind of lay that groundwork that it's
not just going to be a blank slate to
sell property less than fair market
value as many checks many checks and
balances
on top of that we're going to put
covenants and restrictions on the deed
sometimes a reverter clause is important
especially if we're selling something
say to a town with historic restrictions
that property is sold with those
conditions for a very specific purpose
so if that purpose no longer
is needed in the future
we want to make sure before it's sold
off say for a different purpose that
that referter kicks in and that property
is offered with a new appraisal back to
the Department
so in summary the proposed legislation
it does offer some management options
for disposing of challenging properties
I should say for the Department
but the the the goal is to
um make sure that it's in the overall
public benefit so
with that I'm open for questions
thank you and uh if I if you would
indulge me to go first here
so at present
um the is there an appraisal on this
property
yes there are a hundred thousand dollar
property is this uh yeah
um
there is an appraisal I'm not sure
that's public information at this time
uh but we have
uh a staff appraiser in the Bureau of
right away has conducted an appraisal
they've valued the property with
historic restrictions and without so we
actually have two values
um obviously without restrictions
Garner's a higher value okay so I'm fine
with that so
at present if if we went through the
normal process it would be offered to
the town first
so if the town what's what's the
restriction on what the town would have
at present not with this document I have
in front of me
what would the town would the town
have to pay market value yes the way the
current legislation is is fair market
value
so there is no exception as written to
that rule so that that even applies to
towns so in in the the way it is right
now the town could say we want to
purchase that property because we must
we have enough who do we have the
obligation to on this property is it a
Federal Highway or who do we have the
obligation to
I'm sorry could you repeat that who do
we have the obligation to pay funds back
to for this property when it's sold
uh this is this is a hundred percent
Turnpike property so the funds will go
100 back to turnpikes
okay thank you for that
so let's say your legislation passes the
Senators legislation passes
the pro the this the commissioner and
long range uh come to determination that
they're going to sell this for a lesser
value
for some reason that I can't even begin
to understand on that explanation I
heard for social
and then at some point in time as one
Representatives mentioned that this use
doesn't make sense
I have a historical society in my town
that we turn property over to and then
five years later we have it back except
now we're spending the money now to
bring this property back to a sellable
feature
it would only make sense that there's
going to be a substantial Improvement
made to this property but for some
reason some let's say I'll use another
word out of here economic reason that
use doesn't continue but am I wrong to
assume that the that the state has to
buy it back then at the market value
so in a sense if the worst case scenario
happened and the state were to transfer
this property over to some entity and at
some point in time that entity can't
make a go of it and then we're subjected
to market value we may end up being
buying a property back for more we sold
am I missing something there
representative McConkey no that's
exactly how I read this current
legislation
under lines 14 and 15
basically it clearly says if the town
city county decides to resell the
property shall first be offered the
property back to the state at the market
value at the time of sale so that could
be pretty far down the road that could
be a much different value at that time
thank you any other questions yes
represent Jack uh thank you Mr chairman
and thank you for uh thank you for
coming uh if we were to pass line four
through nine as it is uh I don't find
anything in there that uh requires it to
follow the existing long-range process
as you've said that you would but there
doesn't seem to be anything to require
it number two it seems to change the
appraisal process from the way we
normally do it now that either your
department does it or they have an
outside appraiser do it to the governor
and Council determines the fair market
value and not the appraisal process that
we currently use and I don't see
anything in in the language about
covenants that requires a reversionary
clause and is that your normal what's
this what's the authority by which you
would add a reversionary clause on a
sale now
yeah that's a good that's a great
question representative Jack thank you
for the question
um right now the authority is to be able
to put conditions on the sale to protect
the state interest under this current
statute
um
and then there's some there's some other
General
um statutes that the department uses and
I I can't think of those right off the
top of my head but they're General
enough where we if we feel like there's
a a need for caring forth restrictions
say it's a mitigation property and
there's covenants that run with the land
we would have to offer those with you
know as a package deal to whomever wants
to purchase those
thank you yeah uh represent Faulkner
I'm sorry to get back to this one thing
paragraph two does not apply to any I
mean by its own wording
does not apply to anything that's
covered in a paragraph 1A it says except
as provided in paragraph 1A so
this whole thing about the city having
selling it back to the state of market
value
only applies to paragraph one which is
if the city accepts it at full market
value
and anyway paragraph two doesn't require
the state to buy it back it just gives
it State the you know first option to
buy it back
if if it's if it's sold to this to the
town under paragraph one
yeah full market value
if the state wants it back from the town
it doesn't have to take it but if it
does it's pays full market value at the
time that's all that says
none of that has anything to do with 1A
which is a totally separate category and
when a
provides for its own resale value
through the covenants and restrictions
is that
is that the proper reading of this
statute
yeah representative Faulkner I believe I
think you explained it well
thank you
yes representative Newton
thank you Mr chairman
um could you give me an approximate of
how many properties a state owns at this
law
would affect is it one property is it 10
is it a hundred is it a thousand pieces
representative Newton that's a great
question I don't have the exact number
in front of me but it would be
um
it would be a fair number I don't I
don't have an exact number at this time
questions
does the state still still get land
through imminent domain for the highway
in federal and Turnpike
projects and is some of that land that's
not needed or not used
does that can that then be sold for
economic benefits
president Newton yes the answer the
answer is yes
one last question it seems to me not too
long ago we just passed a constitutional
amendment that doesn't allow for land to
be purchased or taken by imminent domain
for economic benefits so how would that
apply to our constitution
if you just said that that land can be
sold once it's been taken for economic
for uh yeah for domain two we sold for
economic profit thank you for the
question representative and I think I
misunderstood your question there so uh
the first part of your question was does
the department acquire land through
imminent domain the answer is yes that's
for project development Highway purposes
when the project is built and whatever
remnants are left over after the
Project's built then there's a separate
process
that we go through in order to determine
the market value and the conditions that
we're going to sell those Surplus
properties back to the public so it's
not always
it's not always at an economic gain I
guess uh you know especially especially
after our project's been built so uh
oftentimes they're they're Remnant
pieces after the project is built yeah
thank you represent bogert please
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um I'm going to go back to after
understanding Roman numeral two
disqualifies is disqualified as of any
significant purpose whatsoever based on
the fact that 1A trumps it and I presume
that uh
all cells of excess land would then be
followed under 1A
so with that being said there's no
Clauses or anything for for and what
I've heard only towns and cities and
stuff like that or
able to sell it back to the state but in
this case the one property is
is none of the above
so how does all that fit
with this because
I'm kind of confused now between
help me to understand please
yeah I think that's a great question
representative Bogart
um I don't think I'm probably the best
person to answer that question that's a
pretty technical question that I would
want to table until we had a chance to
internally discuss that
further questions
if I could follow up on my esteem that
this were to uh
to pass through the house and to be
voted
then there's a whole nother layer if I
heard you correctly then you're going to
have to get the feds to agree that
um that you have the ability now on a
rewrite that you can dispose of
properties for less than fair market
value
and I think you say that you look at
that every five years how far how far
how many years our years out are we that
you normally would have done that
representative McConkey that's a great
question as well we're about a year four
so we're actually in the process of
reviewing a right-of-way manual right
now and coming up with proposed changes
and I I guess this would be something I
I tell my committee not to indulge in
but I'm I'm going to ask you what would
you believe
this this committee deals on a um on
every other year basis uh the highway
fund
and we're struggling struggling
struggling to pave roads but one of the
one of the in bridges and keep the
infrastructure working but but one of
our crown jewels to date has been our
Turnpike system
our Turnpike system is self-funding
roads are in good shape and so forth but
the turnpike system is under tremendous
um
tremendous Peril because a lot of our
Turnpike was funded improvements were
funded on on tolls and and there's
pressure to remove those toll booths off
of that and that translates to less of
Revenue
and requires the turnpike system to work
even more diligent
if I understand correctly from one of
one of the conversations here that this
may not be a one-off this might be many
can the turnpike sustain giving away
property for less than market value and
and still maintain a system that we
enjoy
representative McConkey so first off
um
I don't believe if this legislation went
through that it would be many properties
that would qualify to go through at less
than fair market value okay so I really
don't see turnpikes being targeted for
this type of legislation
I think turnpikes uh you know they have
a lot of a lot of properties that are
currently being used and there's a high
demand for those so even past projects
uh that were
uh
that were
contemplated are still on the books and
we know there's a high value for that
property so we we're not necessarily
open to selling those type of properties
at less than fair market value
thank you any other questions for a
gentlemen yes representative
yes
a lot of words
that I was thinking but couldn't
formulate as well as you did so with
with that if I can go back I have this
Vision in my head of Union Station in
Washington DC okay it's an active
railway station it's a Depot it's a main
tourist attraction and there are
restaurants and shops and whatever in
there
so I don't I cannot visualize this
property but it's apparently historical
train station
probably very well located center of
town area and on an acre or so of land
so if this legislation passed would that
prevent
just for an example of a developer
coming in saying hmm I can keep a facade
and it will retain its historical value
but they or whatever the corporation
would be willing to pay a big amount of
money for it
to put it turn it into for example some
kind of housing luxury condos whatever
and that money could go into the
turnpike system would that
all be prohibited if this legislation as
written passed
representative Newman I'm not sure how
to answer that that question that was
that's a good question I don't have an
answer right thank you any further
questions at this point we have several
other cards
thank you sir all right thank you
for the Senators that are here for the
second hearing uh relative to Hilton
Park boat ramp I apologize we're having
a spirited conversation I could see that
we could be running a half hour late
before we get to you folks
I would like to recognize Ben Frost
please
Ben welcome to Public Works once again
thank you very much Mr chairman
my name is Ben Frost I'm the deputy
executive director and chief legal
officer for the New Hampshire Housing
Finance Authority and I'm here to
express New Hampshire housing support
for this legislation as passed by the
Senate there have been lots of really
good questions here and appreciate Mr
Smith's very Adept answers to most of
them I do want to point out a couple
things and this is reflective of some of
the questions I've heard from you to
Senator Perkins quoka and to Mr Smith
um
with regard to line five
that's the historical social
environmental or economic benefits so Mr
Mr Smith pointed out that does come from
the Federal Highway Administration and
he gave you the CFR citation to that I
heard Mr chairman you expressed concern
about the breadth of that and not
knowing exactly what is meant by social
and I certainly understand that if you
were to seek to limit the scope of this
legislation I would strongly encourage
you to include
affordable housing as a purpose
for sale by the state
of surplus property
subject to appropriate covenants under
RSA 204d which is a surplus land statute
New Hampshire housing has what effects
if is effectively a preemptive right to
acquire Surplus property from the state
that is we jump ahead of city and town
interests when it is for the purpose of
development of affordable housing and I
think I don't think anyone in this room
has hasn't heard that we have an
affordable housing crisis in the state
um
so I strongly encourage you to keep that
in mind we do have we have an excellent
relationship with the department and we
have ongoing discussions over uh Surplus
land that the department intends to
Surplus and we they give us an
opportunity to look at those properties
and determine whether we New Hampshire
housing have an interest in acquiring
those properties for the purpose of
development of affordable housing
throughout the state so it's not we're
not talking about one town
we're talking about the entire State
wherever dot is surplusing property most
of the properties we have no interest in
because they're just not suitable for
affordable housing development they're
not suitable for Housing Development
period they may be in commercial zones
they may be strips of land that only the
abutter would be interested in
so we're we're highly selective in in
choosing properties that we express
interest in
um
with regard to things like the
reversionary clause and that the
conditions that the department may put
on the transfer of property keep in mind
and this has already been said but I
want to re-emphasize this this still
goes through long-range and GNC
the department the commissioner does not
have the final word on this you
effectively do and then followed by GNC
um I'll stop there I put in for two
minutes but I'd be happy to take any
questions
oh I think we'll take you for more thank
you Miss Frost I appreciate you being
here
um I will um so at present when
properties being disposed of it's your
understanding
um that affordable housing is
can make a claim on a property before
the town can is that what you said to me
that is correct okay and at present if
it was determined that this was a
project that was agreeable for
affordable housing you would be
conditioned presently to pay the market
value of that property in most
circumstances yes certainly we're uh
Highway funds or Turnpike funds are
involved that is that is definitely the
case
all right I I understand but if we if
you want to add if if someone wanted to
add you in the list for getting for less
than market value you'd be happy with
that also is that what you well we we
would because uh to develop
affordable housing on land that is
acquired at full fair market value is
difficult if not in some cases
impossible
the
ability of the commissioner in effect to
negotiate with New Hampshire housing on
what a discount might be appropriate
recognizing that the property would then
be used for affordable housing with
long-term restrictions on the use
uh then I'd say that that is a in effect
a social good
and if I could I would imagine you've
probably
how many units of affordable housing do
you think that this is possible to um
renovate do whatever and would you would
you be would someone that wanted to
wanted to make affordable housing there
be hindered by an historical designation
uh Mr chairman those are two separate
and distinct questions I'll address the
first one to the extent I'm able
we don't know all um
there's a I assume I assume a public
listing of state-owned properties yes
there is but it's many thousands of
properties and most of them uh we would
have no interest in
uh there are some parcels of land that
dot currently owns or controls on behalf
of the State uh that would be really
suitable for affordable housing
development and it might be on a
particular parcel it might be 50 units
it might be 100 units it might be 20
units it really depends upon the
individual parcel I'm speaking of this
this this piece of legislation is
starting out as a targeted piece of
legislation for the for the disposal of
one piece of property in this town I'm
speaking of that property is it I I have
no knowledge of that parsley okay thank
you thank you for that uh questions
response
yes represent Barber
so
dot has oversight of property is it the
property that's already been paid for or
is it property that has been bonded
sold or purchased via bonds and stuff so
that the state is still paying for this
land and then
sell it for less than what we are paying
for it if we're still paying for it it's
kind of like a multi-level question
there representative I assume we're not
talking about the individual parcel in
just the town of Newington Newington no
I'm not because this is this is more
General than one piece of property so
that's why I'm
asking my understanding is that this is
only that is the the statutes we're
talking about uh this RSA 439c RSA 440
which is the general surplusing of land
statute that deals with properties that
are already owned in fee by the state uh
they're not sub they're not a purchase
and sale agreement it's not a not a
condition of acquisition it's property
that are already owned by the state and
hence that's that's where the the
surplusing the concept of surplusing
comes in
they are deemed to be Surplus for the
needs of the state
thank you any further question
thank you thank you very much
um I'd like to bring
um Lulu Pickering am I correct about
that
please come forward Newington Historical
Society
I haven't done a pink card yet but I
thought it might be a little if you if
you could afterwards please and Ladies
If you could do your best to if if
something's already been um
uh spoke of or to contain I'd love to
hear everything you have to say but if
you can contain the conversation some I
would appreciate it
welcome to public works thank you very
much and I won't go through the uh
information that I put online under the
remote because I think there were so
many questions today and I've been
involved in this process for five years
so I can help give you some information
that I think will be very helpful
this legislation is not meant to just be
for the Newington railroad Depot the
reason we're here is we ran into a
particular state law that became very
difficult for us and so he said well
everybody shouldn't have to run into
this brick wall if there's a reason to
amend the law then we should do it so
all of the non-profits benefit
the questions about the language and the
bill itself
you're right the very top of this
language is an exception it doesn't
modify all of the other ways that
property are declared to be Surplus it
does not modify whatever the long-range
Planning Commission does it does not
modify anybody's Authority on State
properties for the market value that's
not what we're trying to do
we're trying to say that in certain
circumstances
exceptions should apply
now I think it could help you a lot to
understand how we got into the situation
we're in today
this property has been owned by the
state of New Hampshire for well over 70
years
it was taken by eminent domain when the
general Sullivan Bridge was built so
what the state wanted to do
I'll try to talk into the microphone I'm
sorry did you say seven years or 70. 70
it has been owned for 70 years
what the state said it would do when it
took the property by eminent domain was
it was going to create a public park on
the Newington side of the bridge and
then it created Hilton park on the Dover
side of the bridge Hilton Park got
created the Newington Park never got
created that's what the Newington
Historical Society wants to do
now the property itself is state-owned
property by state rules and laws it's
supposed to be maintained it's in
deplorable condition
now everybody knows money's tight
Highway turnpikes they have a lot of red
listed Bridges they have to decide how
do they prioritize their money
well historic preservations not high on
that list
and so the next thing I'd like to say
is when we came to the general Sullivan
bridge and this massive expansion of the
highway through Newington through Dover
and on the bridge
the Federal Highway the state the DOT
said that they were going to preserve
the federal the general Sullivan bridge
for its historic value
as mitigation of all of the other
impacts that the highway was having on
our area
they didn't
they allowed the bridge to further
deteriorate they came back 15 years
later and said now we want to destroy
the bridge
so now we have two properties state or
or Highway owned properties
supposed to be maintained were not
maintained and we like historic
preservation we want to preserve one of
the oldest Parts in the whole state of
New Hampshire
for public use
so we go through a long and protracted
section 106 process
the language that you see at the
beginning of this bill that talks about
I mean it's the questions you've had
uh that talks about
what are these historical social
environmental or economic benefits
all of that language comes out of every
environmental impact study that the
highway has to do on any project that it
has it is an integral part of the
section 106 process of how do you then
mitigate an adverse impact on a historic
structure so we're not trying to coin
new phrases we're trying to say work
with the language that everybody
understands that they're routinely doing
these studies anyway so that they can
understand what those mean
so the end of the section 106 process
what I can share with you
now the state and Dot want to destroy
the general Sullivan Bridge
we were successful in saying if you do
that
we want you to help preserve the
railroad Depot property which you have
owned for 70 years and done nothing with
it was a difficult negotiation to get
through that process is not easy
but we got through the process
and the property was go it was assessed
it was determined to be Surplus property
it went through the whole long-range
Planning Commission plant system
so it was decided yes this is Surplus
property we can use it as a mitigation
factor for the general Sullivan Bridge
so the offer after four years of very
hard work
the property would be transferred at no
cost to the town of Newington
it would come with a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars because the building
has left rotting in place with very
little maintenance
it would come with a building assessment
to say here's the priority things that
you have to remedy on the building in
the approximate cost
and it would come with a land survey
that shows where all of the shoreline
setback things are where the evasive
species are all of that was the offer
now for the first two years the town
Selectmen were very much on board very
encouraging
but Selectmen change constantly
we now in the last three years have
three new Selectmen on a three Selectmen
board we've had four new Selectmen in
six years
their priorities change
but what we heard from them and this is
not unique to us
well we heard from them is we have too
many historic properties already we
don't need another one
that's happening all across the state of
New Hampshire that's not unique to us
so if the public entities
don't want to work with the properties
to fix them
the state didn't D.O.T didn't Federal
Highway did not
the town says it's more than we can
handle
but you do have non-profit organizations
who are public
organ they're public in a sense they
provide public benefit to the people
we're a private organization because
we're Incorporated
but you can't be a 501c3 organization
unless you have a public aspect to what
you're trying to do
we want to preserve the building it will
come with a whole series of preservation
restrictions it's a historic building we
will have to satisfy all of the
Secretary of the Interior standards for
how you deal with the historic building
we already have been working with
fundraising with Grant organizations
working with groups like The New
Hampshire preservation Alliance
we want to do this
but the only thing standing in our way
to do something that the state has not
done for 70 years
D.O.T doesn't want to preserve historic
properties
the only thing standing in our way is
what the exception to this bill is
supposed to solve
the language that says that the property
can only be transferred to the public
entity the
County the town or the city completely
bars us as a non-profit organization
from accepting what is a beautiful offer
that we've worked five years through
section 106 process to bring to the
table
so we were told no if the town doesn't
want it you can't have it we have to
sell it
now I think if we want to preserve
things in New Hampshire we want to help
with a budget we want to help with the
highway we want to help with all of the
roads and bridges but we also have to do
what we can for all of these cultural
social historic housing the things that
benefit people we need to do those too
um and so I guess I'll say that's my
rant I thank you for listening to me but
I'm very happy to answer any questions
and Jennifer is maybe I could just give
30 seconds and then turn it back to Lulu
if you have any questions so for the
record I'm Jennifer Goodman the
executive director of the New Hampshire
preservation Alliance
um so just wanted to offer a Statewide
perspective from a non-profit historic
preservation group uh really encourage
your support of this exception so that
properties like the one that um Lulu
Pickering just described could be helped
kind of knitting together what other
people have said I think these are
Surplus properties kind of the orphans
in the system and there will be a a
special group where there's
um the right kind of actor the right
kind of non-profit if this exception
moves forward the right kind of property
that will even seek this kind of
exception and then as others have said
before me there'll be a very rigorous
process to evaluate rather that
exception can be made what the value is
and these restrictions that will run
with the property into the future
um I can think of I don't have an
inventory for you but I can certainly I
I welcomed Mr Smith's comments about
properties like this Newington Depot
that have been kind of left stranded
after a mitigation process where they
were saved as part of this mitigation
process for the public benefit but then
they haven't been stewarded because it's
sort of not in the Wheelhouse for the
state
um so I can think of some other historic
a couple of historic Farms over my 20
years at the historic preservation
organization that would have benefited
from this kind of exception where a
willing non-profit could have stepped up
and and made that kind of investment and
benefited the community around it
um so again just there's there's
certainly always going to be pressures
to keep the coffers as full as possible
in those Highway funds I think this is a
unique group of properties that if this
exception would go forward would really
benefit the communities that they stand
in
and as you know I think
non-profits in some cases are often very
well positioned to take on this kind of
effort they have a narrower focus a
narrower Mission what better position
with the right kind of expertise and
access to philanthropic or other dollars
to make these kind of a win-win
situation so I just wanted to offer that
context
all right
let's push the button
we're live thank you
um man Pickering thee did I did I hear
you say that a number of years ago an
agreement was reached with DOT to
mitigate some of the um some of the um
closing from the the general Sutherland
Bridge which is a near and dear property
to my heart
yeah they
and that the the dot was going to turn
that over to the town of Newington for a
dollar or for zero funds and if that was
the case why didn't your folks step
forward and say I'll take it for nothing
foreign
there's two different processes that
took place in 2007 when the first work
started on the expanding the highway the
Spalding Turnpike and the bridges
there was a section 106 process that was
done and the conclusion of that process
was that the state
dot Federal Highway were supposed to
save the general Sullivan Bridge so that
it could be used for this
recreational people access across the
river
then you have to fast forward about 10
15 years and they came back with a
supplemental environmental in Impact
statement that said no it's too
expensive now way too expensive we can't
do it
when we started the section 106 process
it will show us what you did to maintain
that bridge in the 12 15 years that you
were supposed to maintain it and almost
nothing happened
and I think the reasoning is why put
money into an old bridge if you let it
sit there long enough you can make a
valid argument that it costs too much to
fix it
now is that good or bad I don't know but
it's how the system works I understand
that I understand that and uh this
committee's been very involved to
discontinue that bridge I understand the
but I thought there was mention at some
point that the town through the Federal
Highway and through D.O.T had offered
that property to the town for a dollar
did I hear something
no with a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars to help you preserve it why
didn't why didn't the town take it then
when they were in agreement and then
turn it over to you folks then
we have actually made the request both
to the town of Newington and to the DOT
to say if you if neither one of you want
to maintain and preserve this property
and the Historic Society does
will you accept it and turn it over to
us give us all of the responsibility to
maintain the property and they said no
the town said no because they thought
that well you can still come to town
meeting and ask the townspeople to help
you fund it that was one of the things I
heard
the planning board didn't want to
because it's like hey if it goes into
private hands you can the question about
can you get more property taxes from a
private owner that could develop it into
something yes so there's a financial
incentive not to preserve a historic
property
dot said no we said well if the town
won't transfer it to the Historic
Society will you lease it to us long
term with all of the responsibility and
the answer we got to that is that
they're already so far down this process
that they don't want to have to
backtrack on it
okay I just want to narrow my my
question back too
they're at one point dot in Co-op if I'm
wrong with the blessing of the federal
uh Highway was would have given the
property to the town for zero and giving
you a hundred given the town a hundred
and fifty thousand dollars to to help uh
renovate or whatever to preserve that
property did the town say no to that
the official offer has not been made but
over the last two years as we've gone
through this process the memorandum of
understanding the section 106 process
there came a point in time when the town
was like no we're not going to accept it
okay thank you I'll come back and sdot
are there are there other questions for
uh
the two
thank you so much for your testimony
thank you very much
could could I bring dot forward again
and ask that question
so could do you have any knowledge or
can you get back to us on on that
question that the the feds and Dot had
made an offer to the town we were
hearing mitigation for other things do
you know the answer to that or can you
get back to us on that
am I on yes come on representative
makagi I'll get back to you I don't know
the exact answer on that thank you we'll
we'll uh we'll probably suspend and so
we can get that but while while we're
here I would like to hear from the last
speaker if I could
uh Mr Gilbert from
um Newington New Hampshire representing
himself in support of the bill
Mr Gilbert welcome to public works thank
you my name is William Gilbert I'm from
Newington I'm a member of the Newington
Historical Society uh not really an
officer but I do a lot of the heavy
lifting because of my young age I guess
um Miss Pickering did a great job of
outlining
uh the legal steps that were taken
um I'm going to tell you about what what
the humans felt at the time uh and I
want to emphasize that we're not here
just for newington's railroad station
we're here to try to help other
historical societies to not have to go
through what we went through this is
what we went through
um
sort of pre-covid 2018-2019 there was a
lot of enthusiasm we said hey we're
gonna we can get this train depot which
is very very small building by the way
uh and it was in mitigation because
they're going to do something with the
general Sullivan Bridge a lot of ideas
were being thrown out it's like hey
maybe we can get some girders and build
a little Monument to it with a plaque
describing the purpose of the general
Sullivan Bridge the history uh maybe you
know a great place to hold a wedding uh
we have lots of archives in the
Newington Historical Society about the
railroad Depot we could maybe make a
little Railroad Museum on the first
floor uh who knows maybe a little
caretaker up above that could you know
take care of the lawns in exchange for
for rent and things were going great
under Ms pickering's uh tutelage they
were memorized by standing the select
board at the time was very supportive of
her uh and then comes the spring of 2021
and our three-man board as she said
turns over we so we had a new selectman
and in April uh we we were going to have
a meeting and we thought it was going to
be a great done deal we had our State
Rep was there we had a representative
from DHR was there and we might have had
someone from the preservationist and
last but I'm not sure uh but at that
meeting we thought it was going to be
everyone's going to vote Yes and we got
a uniform we don't want this property
don't pursue it any further there was
talk of oh Shoreline mitigation fear
factors going on there
to say we were
surprised non-plussed and shocked it was
an understatement and that event that
happened to us that is the Genesis of SB
258 and I thank you for your time
thank you are there any questions for
the gentleman
seeing none thank you sir
I am I am going to um I'm going to
recess this hearing at this point in
time
to to gather more information I am not
going to be a time certain I'm going to
post it in the calendar we still have
plenty of time before we have to exec
this bill out and if that's okay with
the with the committee
I think we have more information that we
need to gather
so with that I will recess out of
out of Senate Bill 258 to to a time to
be noticed in in the calendar
thank you
you're worse welcome
yeah
I thought we went afternoon it'd be easy
thanks
foreign
okay why don't we and I apologize for
the late hour members need to need a
five minute break
okay let's uh I apologize Senator we're
going to give the committee five five
minutes if you could
thank you
foreign
Waters um welcome to public works I'm
sorry for the delay that you had to
endure but I would like to open up the
hearing on Senate Bill 228 FN relative
to Hilton Park boat ramp please sir
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee Senator David Waters district
for introducing Senate Bill 228 relative
to the Hilton Park boat Ram so we're now
Crossing about a half a mile across
Hilton point from Newington over to
Dover
um so what this bill tries to address is
the deteriorating condition of the boat
ramp and the absence of a dock where
there used to be one in Hilton Park
and um their the condition there is that
the boat ramp itself
um potholes deterioration of pavement so
it's all about unusable now
and then years ago there used to be a
dock there so that boats could come in
and tie up at the dock people could fish
from it and and so on and that dock um
deteriorated and was taken down a number
of years ago now the concerns around um
this is to be good to have a launching
place there
um you know in terms of a public
launching place in the Great Bay it's
either something around here you go to
go down all the way down to new Fields
uh down there so there's real interest
in
um serving Boulders and Fishers in this
in this area
um and a number of years ago we tried to
do something about this
um at during the time when the
construction was beginning on all the
bridges down there
um Dover had a particular interest at
that point too and being able to get its
um rescue boat that it would have a
place that it might be able to come into
a dock and offload somebody onto an
ambulance we also headed that time just
the beginnings of development
aquaculture industry and uh the folks up
in that part of the bay thought it'd be
very nice to be able to bring their
boats in somewhere
um as as well but because of the
construction project we just had to put
that on on pause because there was so
much else going on there and most of the
park was taken up with construction uh
project so um that's why we began to
re-initiate these discussions this uh
this past year about okay now what what
can we do here
um the reason we're coming before you
with this bill to create this committee
is there some issues which I'll describe
and so the bill says okay we need a
committee that can come together and
resolve these issues so we'll see if we
can't get
um the boat ramp repaired and
potentially construction of a dock
the issues here um are is that that land
is owned by the Department of
Transportation
and the Department of Transportation
under its Federal
requirements must sell this land at full
market value and a number of years ago
we had an appraisal you know a million
or so dollars for that fine you know
that's that's the law that's what that's
what would need to be done
so to whom Would It Go
well fish and game because they operate
the boat ramps around the state
to two problems with that
one is that a fishing game owns it and
operates it there cannot be commercial
activities
so the aquaculture folks couldn't use it
the gondola
couldn't tie up there on the dock either
the second problem of Fish and Game runs
it
is that
um
they under their rules for boat ramps
would have to ban parking aside from
that of the trailers that are being
brought in in that area and they would
have to have someone staff that boat
ramp
so
um and then add to that is we'd need a
couple million dollars maybe maybe more
to build to build the um
build the dock the ramp repairs not so
much
so
um
it turns out as well though that this is
kind of timely because there is federal
funding
um the federal delegation has been been
contacted there is federal funding for
uh Waterfront projects Coastal projects
in various bills at this point in time
so the potential is there that the money
to buy it
and then the money to construct the dock
could be secured through federal grants
so what this envisions is a committee
that will see if there is a way forward
to solve that problem of the transfer of
the property
and the management of it
one possibility that has emerged is that
peace Development Authority has said
well we might be willing to take on the
management of this
and that would mean that fish and Gabe
wouldn't have to staff it that we
wouldn't have the parking prohibitions
and that the agriculture folks could
potentially use that dock now so there's
the possibilities if we have the
committee get together put together a
report look at these things then we'll
see
what is what might be possible for it
so that's that's the bill Mr chairman
thank you questions for Senator
representing
actually I got a couple Mr chairman the
first one is
something that we do with on both sides
of the wall with the study requests it's
uh says that the studies shall include
representatives of the aquaculture
community
uh but below that it says other
interested parties do you have objection
to removing representatives of the
agriculture Community I ask that because
every time when we put in a nebulous
thing into the bill like representatives
of the aquaculture committee our staff
spends days if not weeks tracking down
who what how it should be and it just
complicates
thank you for your question I've avoided
that problem because no it's not setting
up a committee with members it says at
this point it's it's consultation with
those folks so they would have to not
have to ask folks to be members of this
group
it's just I'm listening to folks that
they would cons they would consult with
bringing to talk with them so that's why
online you see on on the line
um
consultation on line 10. and that's what
governs these other folks so you're
going to have Dot and uh fish and game
get together and PDA and then they'll
consult with the other folks listed on
line 10 on so it avoids the problem
you're talking about and a follow-up
place and
can you tell me any other boat ramp in
the state of New Hampshire that fishing
game does or has to staff
um go up to the Lakes
I'm not sure how actively this this
staff to one down in in new Fields um
but they said in this but they said in
this particular place because of the
nature of that parking
situation they felt they would have to
have somebody there to enforce the no
parking by others that's just what they
said
so
thank you
further questions for Sandra Waters
if if I could
so it's been a number of years since I
was at that property used to stop there
all the time
um is and I remember the boat ramp and I
think I even possibly remember a doc
the is the ramp still in operation but
in poor condition is that what your
testimony was or they stopped using the
uh
the ramp
um thanks for your question I I look at
that ramp and um you know
I think would be very
sketchy as to whether it really could be
very well used I imagine that people
could try but they're not actively it is
it is in tough shape it's in tough shape
thank you for that
um
so we're not we're not forming a
commission that makes I I will be happy
to take more comment we're not forming a
commission you want to form a study
and the study is I understand it would
be dot fish and game NPS Authority
and then your your you would hold public
hearings to that effect
and other people that were interested
public wanted to attend would have that
opportunity
okay
I understand that any any further
questions for the senator yes
representative Newton thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question uh this study committee that
you want to form to do the Hilton Park
and you say there'd be public hearings
but those public hearings you imagine
them being Statewide or just on the
Seacoast
well thanks for your question let me
just note it doesn't say a study
committee it says these these three
shall study
okay so
um it is a less formal take
but that they should organize a process
where anybody who wants to come in
and they would consult with and so I
would think that would be a fairly open
process
um since there will be no apps they will
report to us
if there were then a proposal to do
something I would think at that point we
would have a full public hearing
process but for this it's like
please get together and see if you can't
work work something out that you can
present to us and then the legislature
could take from there
oh yeah so I apologize for saying uh
study committee that's what it appears
to me but it does say and here shall
provide opportunity for public endpoint
and where do you see that public input
happening is that what you just
explained
well let's answer the question and you
know I I would think that they would uh
hold meetings probably
um you know either uh Dover city hall or
over at uh PDA but if you would feel
more comfortable in including language
to say
um opportunity for a public hearing
that would make some sense wouldn't it
are you all set there yes afternoon yes
represent uh Faulkner
thank you Senator uh
the results of the study if they in fact
recommend some improvement would you
anticipate that we might see that next
to the capital budget process or
as individual legislation
well um
I give them until 2024 June 30th
so they've got a year
and that does kind of Tee It Up for the
following legislative section session in
which there would be legislative
possibilities but also capital budget
possibilities
My Hope Is that on this one
that if it looks like the federal
funding is there
then legislation could say that we
authorize dot to make the appropriate
transfer at market value Etc
and then
um
you know the the Federal grant you know
paid for by Federal grant funding
something some line like that and so
that my hope is it would not have
budgetary
costs to the state but that that just
remains to be determined
representative
thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking the question pull
that a little closer to you if you could
representative
thank you
I'd love to buy this guy in the world
but I'm just curious
are we voting
to build the stock are we voting to
study it
thanks for your question you're voting
to tell
peas D.O.T and fishing game to study to
talk to people and give us a report oh
because up here it says this build
Direction Department of Fish and Game
and Department service station to
construct the boat ramp at Hilton Park
condoba
that's why I asked the question
um they shall study it I think May are
you looking at the as amended or the
original it doesn't say study it's a
build
oh well that's I'm sorry thanks for
thank you so much for pointing it out
that analysis referred to the unamended
version
the the original version of the Senate
said darn it do the doc and that wasn't
going to fly because of the problems I
noted about authority over the property
and management of it so that's why the
replace all Amendment said stay
but thank you I I had looked at that
before I came in and said oh yeah yeah
that's the old one and I'm glad you
pointed out because I can see why the
confusion's there
further questions yes representative
thank you chairman Senator so the goal
would the goal
to con to study or to study the
feasibility of constructing the dock and
then ultimately
transferring the property to maybe P's
Development Authority is that correct to
manage it thank you I mean that's that's
that would be that is the possibility
that came forward that would solve the
problems about ownership transfer and so
forth
uh and so that's why the bill said you
know that's what includes peas because
they came forward and said you know what
we we uh maybe we could maybe run this
um because they do that kind of thing
and they're just across the water
um so that when that offer came forward
said okay let's study let's let's study
and see if that if that is a viable
option and we'll find out from this
study I think they'll probably look at
some cost estimates they'll look more
closely at the finance available from
the federal grants and they'll they'll
let us know what what uh what we can do
thank you
uh and I understand we have another pink
card in the audience if you could get
that passed along so I can see who's
looking to speak and what Andy uh
Senator I'm almost done here
and uh representative
showcased an item of
um
qualifications to be a member of this uh
a member of this group they have you had
conversations with peas Fish and Game
um and are are they are they amicable to
doing this yes okay yeah this thanks for
the question this amendment
um came out of
those conversations that fish and game
D.O.T thought yeah we would it would be
good to do something there they said yes
and you know there's a lot of
conversation getting to this point and
uh they said yes this is a good way to
go because without without appointments
and so forth it seems like uh those
those people could get together to have
this study without this but I fully
understand that if we put this in
legislation and you were able to find a
way for uh Federal funding or whatever
it would hold much more Merit in your
process and going forward thank you yeah
so so I I commend you on that and I mean
so you know how it is sometimes it is
the legislation this is a light touch
this is a very light touch but it is
probably the only way to get this done
okay thank you
um thank you for your testimony sander
thank you
and um
Kathleen would you like to come forward
for New Hampshire D.O.T and testify at
this point
I apologize if you could state your name
and welcome once again to Dio to Public
Works sure
um chairman McConkey members of the
committee Kathy Mulcahy hamson I'm the
senior hearings examiner for the
Department of Transportation my honor to
appear before you this afternoon
the Hilton Park boat ramp area is owned
by turnpikes
um and I'd refer to it for DOT anyway as
a pro a problem
um property
beautiful
waterfront property is a problem for us
because it's not what we do
they want to construct a boat ramp and a
dock and again not what D.O.T does we
would like to see another entity that is
better equipped to manage the property
take it over and have it for good public
use
which we're not able to do we want an
entity that can be a good Steward of the
property and make that work for the
public
we're happy to work in with the other
agencies and entities to look at
transferring this property I don't know
that we'd have a lot to say about the
construction of the doc facility had a
best construct that and the funds for
that but we're happy to look at the best
ways to transfer that over to another
entity that can make better use of the
property
thank you any questions
yes represent Jack uh thank you uh am I
correct because this is Turnpike owned
that there wouldn't be any issue of
having to return something to Federal
Highway yeah
a return to Federal Highway on this
good question anyone else yes
representative Newton
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
this bill does keep the dot involved
with this project and I'm wondering
conceptual plans and ideas and
feasibility studies sometimes come with
a large cost
how much of that can be done
in-house and you know thousands and
thousands of dollars is going to have to
be spent for this study I call a study
committee to go anywhere where's that
money coming from
um so it's not within Dot's wheelhouse
to um do feasibility studies on
construction of the dock or anything or
the fishing facilities that that's not
what we do so I imagine that would be
with fish and game or peas that isn't
what we do what I envision our role on
this um
studying the issues would be to how best
to turn over the property to whichever
entity is going to take it over
thank you
seeing no further questions thank you
I'd like to recognize
um is it Elizabeth Fisher
is this a preferred order between the
two folks okay
Dover New Hampshire supporting the bill
welcome to public works when you're
ready to speak just make sure the
red light is on by depressing the button
up front
thank you good afternoon my name's
Elizabeth Fisher I am a native of Dover
New Hampshire and as a kid I spent many
many hours
and actually as an adult I spend many
many hours on the piscataqua river I'm
going to pass around a little picture
please ignore the stuff on the back I
save paper so I want to pass around two
things one is a picture of the dock that
used to be there and also um a article
from profiles and courage and many of
you profile excuse me magazine many of
you may remember if you've been in New
Hampshire for a long time that was kind
of the magazine that came out on a
monthly basis I'm here to support this
piece of legislation
um
as I said I have spent a lot of time on
the piscataqua river over the years
launching in Dover launching over in
Durham and attempting to launch at
Hilton park with my little 14-foot
Merrimack
um and in all honesty if you back your
trailer down that ramp
um boat launch you may lose a wheel in
the process but we persevere because we
like to sail and it's one place that we
can put
um our boats in so that clearly needs to
be taken care of in the short term if
not in the long term I'm also passing
around a little photograph of the dock
that existed for many many many years
and was used by both people with the
Miramax and if you look at the profiles
you'll see that they had these little
tiny one-person speed boats but there's
also larger larger boats that would like
to be able to utilize that
so I received a phone call from an
organization called Dover 400. we like
Portsmouth are celebrating 400 years of
existence and so they wanted to do
something down at Hill Park and because
that's where it all began and
um I went down and looked around and we
wanted to do a boat uh
tour or a parade a boat parade the
problem is the ramp is in such condition
that it would be dangerous to try and do
that so we'll have to launch those boats
someplace else and we're talking about
moving it up to the Dover Waterfront
um
considering the condition which is
deteriorated from last year I reached
out to Senator Waters and I want to
thank him for his efforts and his
leadership with regards to this to see
if there was something we could do short
term as well as as long term I also
reached out to Senator Shaheen's office
to see because we know that there was
Federal money for infrastructure
and so the solution is for these three
entities to get together to try and
figure out a long-term solution so that
there is adequate Public Access for all
citizens to be able to get onto the
piscata coach kachiko Bellamy and out to
the Al's of Shoals a few years ago I
became a UNH Marine docent and I lead
tours out to appledore and also up and
down the piscata cost so I'm pretty
familiar with that whole area and this
is a jewel that just isn't being
utilized and I want to put my efforts
into trying to to make that happen the
best that that I possibly can so I
appreciate your support of this study I
think there's some solutions that can
come forward I think the players that
Senator Waters has put together are the
right players and and certainly there's
the public support within the boating
community both sailboats as well as
motorboats to to use this space thank
you I think we can work through the
issues are there questions
Elizabeth I'm I must say anyone that
would launch anything only 14 foot long
off of that into that high current area
is a person much braver than myself well
you do it at the slack tide
and then you head upriver thank you
thank you for your testimony thank you
um last card that I have is uh Richard
is it Claiborne sir Clybourn
welcome to Public Works
thank you
my name is Rich Clybourn I'm the
executive director of the gundalo
company located in Portsmouth New
Hampshire we're a 501c3 non-profit
organization whose mission is to protect
the maritime Heritage and the
environment of the piscataqua region
through education and action I'm here
today in support of Senate bill 228. our
organization is focused on developing
the next generation of River and Bay
stewards and we do that by bringing
nearly 2500 students in third fourth
fifth sixth and seventh grade
out on the piscataqua river and uh
introducing them to A New Perspective
most of those kids have never been out
on the water before so when they get out
there they're sort of their jaws hang
open because they've never seen
Portsmouth or places like that from the
water itself
um we use a replica gondolo uh the
piscataqua which was built in 2011.
and we also
offer public sales private Charters and
since 2016 we've offered a summer day
camp which started out with 12 campers
in 2016 and has expanded to 470 in this
past summer and we're looking to be
nearly that number for this coming year
as well
all told we routinely sail with nearly
10 000 passengers each year and hope to
reinforce the ideas of conservation
preservation and sustainability when it
comes to the estuarian environment
contained within the piscatica Watershed
we conduct approximately 20 percent of
our sales up in the Great Bay Little Bay
Area each year
and we travel up from the the dock in
Prescott Park and we dock typically at
the UNH estuarian lab the Jackson lab in
Durham
the renovation of the boat ramp and the
construction of a new boat dock at
Hilton Park would provide this these are
potential benefits I'm not talking that
they're going to happen but potential
benefits would provide an opportunity
for us to expand our education programs
in that area and also could potentially
reduce the costs to schools in Durham
Dover Lee Madbury Nottingham where I
live Barrington Epping places like that
so that would afford us another place to
be able to to dock the gundalo and um
board students and take them out on the
river
the renovated boat ramp and floating
dock would also provide an additional
site to conduct some of our summer camp
programs
which would allow us to reach even more
young people and help to further our
mission
we also see access to Hilton Park from
the floating dock and boat ramp as a
potential site for holding our annual
piscataqua Riverfest
which brings together our non-profit
Partners Maritime theme vendors and
Crafters musicians local food trucks and
includes a wooden boat show showcasing
the time-honored craft of wooden boat
building in the Seacoast area
all with the goal of celebrating the
rivers bays and tributaries in the
Watershed and bringing awareness of the
conservation and preservation efforts
that are related to the waterways going
on throughout the Seacoast
lastly and as Senator Waters pointed out
we do about 20 of our sales up in that
area and having a dock at Hilton Park
would also provide another place for us
to go in the event that we had in
medical emergency on board
uh with an adult or even a child
there are commercial docs in that area
that we could potentially get to but the
issue of getting the First Responders
out to the dock to take care of the
emergency would be the issue there so
having a Hilton Park would allow the
First Responders to get there and be
able to treat any emergencies in a more
timely manner I want to thank you for
allowing me the opportunity to speak to
you in support of this bill
any questions for the gentleman
yes representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
I'm I'm curious I've been at that ramp
at low tide and you can't even hardly
get a boat in and out could you tell me
approximately how what you'd have to do
the size of the gondola the length and
how much water you need to be in to even
come into a dock how how far out do you
have to include dredging or how exactly
would you do that if it was low tide
um so we are the draft on our ship is
two and a half feet
which means that we can go into water
that's about three feet deep at low tide
there we probably would not try to tie
up to a dock because of the shallow
water we would have to time our comings
and goings there based on the tide not
like in Prescott Park we have plenty of
water underneath the dock so there's not
a problem there but other places that we
go we have to be very cautious and um
pruned with our timing to be able to
land thank you yep
any further questions
seeing none thank you sir thank you
we um I see no further cards for any
testimony here
um so
I am going to pull to a close uh Senate
Bill
228 FN as amended by the Senate
and entertain we have the um
we have this noticed as possible
executive session to follow and I would
entertain a motion on Senate Bill 228 FN
as amended
oh
um I rep I recognize representative Jack
uh thank you Mr chairman I move out to
pass
motion by Jack ought to pass secondary
second second by Mills
motion's been made in second in
discussion
yes represent noon thank you
I like the idea of this one I can't
support the bill I was written I think
it's kind of vague
who the authority goes through
and what they're going to come up with
the house
it just seems to be too broad and vague
for me
okay I thank you for that representative
paying for the study
the um
the question is who's paying for the
study they the persons that are part of
that study will fund this will fund this
this project if there are funds the
state of New Hampshire
and Dot is not is not paying for it is
was the testimony that we heard from the
Department
I think I think the vehicle they're
looking to do is to convene a group of
people and let them have a conversation
on how this would evolve and I I think
the senator has kept it Loose that we
know the speaker does not want to see
commissions where at all possible and
and I think I think they're trying to
pull this together and see if those
parties can come to an agreement and see
if there is federal funding available
out there and if so they they could
possibly move forward so it's loot it's
loose by Design I will tell you that
having any money in this so just we we
are not approving any funding with this
represent me
I I'm going to agree with my seat mate
this
it is not uncommon to have bills come
from the other chamber that are similar
to this
that are exceedingly loose
and throw responsibility on other
parties not knowing what they're going
to be and um
to come up with construction costs
who's running the study who's in charge
of it who's going to be part of it it's
so nebulous so loose and I understand
there may be a few people willing to
work together but um
I don't know if there's a whole lot of
people are going to chime in for free
and give you the cost of construction of
a boat ramp of a dock uh particularly
where it's located where it's going to
be a pretty pricey operation to do
um
I just think it's far too nebulous to
let loose on its own even to the point
where they and it still concerns me if
you look at the cover page it says as
amended by the Senate the title is not
amended it directs the department of
fish and game department of
transportation to construct a boat ramp
at Hilton Park in Dover
the title instructs that as amended by
the Senate
so I cannot vote for the bill as is
ripsham Jack uh thank you Mr chairman I
would just point out the title of the
bill is an act relative to the hilden
park boat ramp says nothing about
construction uh the language you're
referring to is in the analysis that was
prepared I guess by oh well I'm not sure
who prepares those OLS
enal study repairs
okay
I do not believe it is
I
will we'll take we'll take comments
first and then there might be an
alternative motion here yes yeah I would
represent new
[Music]
a study committee on this committee
to have one or two meetings if we've got
the time and say hey can we pull
something together on this that's
you know tighten it up enough to wire
liking I guess would be and if we can't
we can't but if we can't I think the
bill warrants the effort to try to do
something
uh is the members suggesting possibly
retaining
okay good time okay
representative Newman
yes just in the collective wisdom of the
senior members of this committee that
the notes that I took Fish and Game
D.O.T and peas development to work
together and study what could be done
and then I made a note study and get a
report together in the past have any of
you all senior people seen anything like
this where you've gotten some groups
that agree to get together
um
and just at least brainstorm what could
be done
um and then they could come back with a
report on
either we need an estimate or you need
an estimate or maybe one of their in
expertise of them that they would have
an idea of what a new boat ramp could
cost I thank you for the question I have
not in my time seen a similar piece of
legislation that was not committing to
the makeup and or a study or what the
result would be
foreign
thank you Mr chairman
um
it seems that I thought this is just so
they could set up and do a study and
they've defined three departments that
should work together to create a study
and that there was no commitment of
money or anything else or even the fact
of building anything yet it's just to
create a study so that I report can be
issued to
all the appropriate heads of States of
our government so that they can review
this then to see if it's worthy
financially worthy of moving forward or
do we just after the study is done then
put it on the shelf and say thank you we
did the study and it's not financially
relevant to our budget so I'm confused
where all these other
issues are because it just says here in
Roman numeral too
that it's going to give a study and it's
going to give it to these people and
it's to be studied by X number of people
thank you thank you for the question
represent Mills did you want to respond
oh yes I did I want to I want to thank
representative Boger because that's my
feeling on this also I also have never
seen anything set up quite this nebulous
and part of the reason that I'm in favor
of it is that first a it doesn't spend
any money it does name the three
entities that have to get together
the worst thing that can happen is if
the three entities decide dot says I'm
not kicking in a dime but I'm ready to
give up the boat ramp Fish and Game says
I want nothing to do with this and peace
goes well I don't want to fight over who
it is this has got a time sensitive data
on it this says the 24 the end of this
fiscal year that's it it dies it goes
nowhere if they if they're all
interested and want to cooperate with
each other then they come up and said
here's the deal this is what we can do
this is what it's going to cost these
are the mechanics here's the new bill we
need this done rapidly so that we can
get federal funds so this bill by itself
it either it just lives or dies they
either get us information or they don't
so I'm fine with it
further discussion
yeah let's do how many advice Jack is
recognized on the advice of council I I
withdraw my emotions
well the second second be withdrawn
I will withdraw my motion okay
there there seems to be uh diverse
opinion on
on the um the legislation before us
I would like to have more consensus I
like the idea of a more study on it or
an amendment that might possibly come to
us that would clear this up so I will
um I will do as we did before we have no
motion before us for
um for approval of this I think I'd like
to recess out of
house bill
228 FN is amended and we will come back
at a date to be posted in the uh in the
calendar to further deliberate this and
we'll notice that as an executive
session at that time Mr chairman just a
question I believe neither one of these
are early bills the bill we heard
earlier and I believe the deadline is
May 11th according to what the uh what
was that the chairs means I believe the
deadline is more at the end of May right
so we've got till the end of May as a
committee to to work on this if we have
a lot of discussion so just to clarify
I'm willing that was a great question
even though it's an FN bill it's we
could be on May 11th but
I will contact the speaker's office to
get a definitive answer on that uh we
are coming we are coming tentatively for
a session on April what was that the
last is the end of April April I think
27th the last I think Thursday in April
which I believe is the 27th so there
might be an opportunity for us to to tag
on to that day or uh but we'll look at
the schedule and see where it is we'll
speak to the sponsors and see if we can
get some clarification on both of these
bills because Mr chairman is just for
everybody we have had committee meetings
after sessions the sessions have been
short or depending on maybe if we have a
a 1pm session we could meet in the
morning or if we have a session gets
done noon 1 pm we could meet in the
afternoon if we have to and we have had
lunch meetings uh typically The Freshman
legislators pay for the pizza for the
day but that we we have several
opportunities there so uh with that I'll
call this uh hearing
recess
thank you Mr chairman
I think yeah the more I listen to it I
think won't be United is committee
I think the questions are all valid yeah
everybody's asking I really yeah I want
to see it happen right yeah right I mean
I think yeah the 228 we can we can amend
it somehow
thank you